[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation this is the third
world builder we've had in this series
Jimmy Wales was here almost a year ago
talking about how Wikipedia came
together and basically is becoming
matched with the world in its scale and
its content and then we had a
combination of Will Wright and Brian you
know down at the herbes Theatre becoming
friends in front of that audience many
of whom are probably here tonight and
they're building spore we're now only
the users are making it but the
program's themselves are generative both
for the graphical elements and the
Knighton
the dynamically systematic functioning
of it much like Sim City only richer and
also the music that's what Brian is
bringing to it Brian's approach on that
just to mention a thing that came up
afterwards is he wants the music
instruments which you use as a user in
Spore to be so good that people will get
the program just for the musical
instruments that's the kind of thing
that happens in these worlds that are
building that's happening in Second Life
it's that wonderful situation where the
creator himself or herself gets to be
surprised by what the creation does once
it's occupied by a lot of creative
people but there's a first creator and
tonight we have one of them Philip
Rosedale
[Applause]
well hello everybody thanks for having
me I'm I am Philip Rosedale otherwise
known as also known as Philip Linden
that's me
in second life and what what Stewart
asked me to talk about here tonight to
the best of my abilities and what I'll
try to do is tell you something about
second life and about what it tells us
about the real world you know what if we
what if I what if we collectively
learned from second life so far
about the real world or about ourselves
so I thought I would do a let me see
here I may have to I'm in this odd yogi
position okay there we go
actually I'm in let's not senior I'm
sitting down you see us
somebody had me sitting missing there
are a lot of sounds in the second life
you always take your chances when you
walk away from the screen there for that
amount of time I don't know why I'm
sitting isn't that interesting all the
second lifers out there like that is is
so strange I'm gonna so I'm gonna start
up here again I've got a I've got a
story here in in three parts and then
what I wanted to do was take some
questions and get everybody to direct me
a little bit in terms of what you want
to see and what we can talk about I
wrote some notes down I wrote them down
with a pen today and then I uploaded
them into second life and then I stuck
them on a piece of paper here and I'm
holding it in my avatars hand so we can
take a look so instead of PowerPoint
we'll just do this
so there we go yeah I'll keep referring
back to that but I thought we'd do three
things I thought I'd kind of tell you
about the the yen of digitizing
everything which is the world around you
and then I would tell you so I'll spend
a little time on that and then I thought
I'd spend some time on the effect it has
on us so digitizing the world means that
you digitize the space and then you
digitize yourself and I think from the
standpoint of discussion those two
things are different enough that they're
sort of two different parts and thoughts
here and then finally my thoughts on
what Second Life tells us about the
future wants to come I guess that's the
that's the hardest part but I thought
I'd start with this issue of digitizing
everything you know we have been
digitizing things pretty aggressively
for the last couple of decades audio and
video in general when we when we
digitize things we generally do it
because it makes them easier to
manipulate easier to share easier to
modify we've seen that happen with media
and so second life in a way asks the
really big question well do we have
enough computing power to just go all
the way rather than you know starting
with these little things like media and
just digitize everything digitize the
whole world and so starting about seven
years ago that's what we
Linden Lab started trying to do we
started writing a lot of software to try
and digitize the whole world you know
why would you do that why would you
digitize everything well the world as
the physical place that we as thinking
people are embedded in was here before
us physics in some sense made us you can
see all this I am I the way this is all
people talking to me let's see can I say
I'm busy
we had a terrible for those who are in
second life in here we had a terrible
upgrade yesterday so you'll see all the
chatter here in the background how many
people in the room like have a second
life account that's really cool so we're
we're getting there so the world the
physical world was here before us and we
as as thinking people can obviously
imagine it a lot better
we ideas like who owns what are things
that are not written into the basic
atomic physics of the world the world
works in a way that doesn't say who owns
things the world works in ways that we
can easily imagine improving on and so I
think that was a lot of the genesis of
Second Life at least for me was this
question of well you know can we take a
computer or a lot of computers and try
and simulate the whole world and so how
would we do that so that so I'll try to
tell you just at a high level so you can
kind of imagine the capabilities here
how we actually did that right so
digital Atomics what did we do so the
world is made of atoms atoms are too
small to simulate with a computer
nowadays and so we imagine from the
start that we were going to do something
where just like you see us now I'm gonna
fly here everyone can fly a course in
second life why not you know I'm flying
around a little island here in second
life and this island is actually being
simulated on one computer it's being
simulated on one server machine so we
have this question of well how can we
how can we simulate a world that is
interesting enough for us to be willing
to engage in and do things in but not
too complicated for us so that we so
that the computers would actually be
able to simulate it and so what we did
and I'll play around a little bit to
show this off was we built a kind of an
atomic system we said that all the
pieces of this world like this little
chunk of that tower bar over there each
one of these little pieces would be our
atoms and so we would sort of build
things like Legos we would we would
build this whole world in place out of
using atoms that were oh about this big
so we'd kind of we'd start with a basic
you know cube in this case this is so
this is the atom in second life that's
the sound of creation isn't that great I
love that it takes a second to load so
so this is an atom so what can I do with
it let me show you that because it's
kind of fun now part of what's really
fun here
is that all of what I'm doing here I can
do with other people I figured I'll show
you that and I'll show you that at the
end but it's really crazy the the
incredible thing here is that all of
this is built in real time with all your
friends sitting next to you telling you
what to do or even working on it with
you together but this this is a digital
atom so what can I do with it well I can
do a bunch of things with it I can I can
I you know I can change I can certainly
you know do simple stuff like change
what color it is you know I can I cannot
I showed you me stretching it there a
little bit I can I can make it
shiny I can I can cut it and this is
important you know you ask like well
what are you know what's the shape of an
atom the idea here in second life was to
make the whole definition of this object
here take up you know 20 or 30 bytes so
it would be a very compact little
genetic representation that would tell
me what this what this object looks like
I can you know I can I can share it I
can twist it I can even make it I can do
just about anything I want with it so
that's kind of an atom now let's now
it's also physical so it exists in a
real world here so I can I can pick it
up even though I've even though I've got
something in my hand here I can I can
pick it up and throw it over there I can
throw it at somebody else and you can
imagine there's a whole world of
experience that comes with that so
there's a physics engine that is
animating the environment here
everything is being continuously
simulated the other thing I can do in in
the real world
objects have all these unusual
interactive capabilities a like a
personal computer in the real world is
built out of electronics you know some
mechanical physics and then electrons
moving around so we sort of said well
are you gonna make things interactive if
I want to make this big weird object
here do something interesting how am I
going to do that well again to kind of
cheat and not use so much computing
power we created a scripting language a
programming language that lets me now
take that little object and attach a
little bit of programming to it so that
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
say when I when I touch that object I
want it to change its color and so I'm
editing its
right now again somebody could be
sitting next to me while I do this and
there we go so that says when I when I
touch that object I want it to say
touched let's say hello Stuart and I
save that that little bit of code is now
transferred to the server where we are
and that object is now also running this
little piece of program and so if I
touch it it changes its colour and it
says hello Stuart now this object can
also talk to the web so it can talk to
intelligent systems that are running on
machines on the Internet
not just on Second Life it can exchange
information with them it can communicate
with other people it could tell you when
your friends come by act as a doorbell
send you an email when your friends and
second-life come by to see you
can do just about anything the language
that we wrote is pretty fast
in fact on this island right now there
are probably about 3000 or so
objects like that that are all doing
things in fact this whole island is
about as many as 15,000 or so of those
little tiny objects all being
continuously simulated by the computer
if you look up in the air you'll see
some clouds the clouds in Second Life
are a fluid simulation it's also running
on the same computer and that fluid
simulation spreads across the whole
system in fact there are at this point
around closing in on 5,000 computers
about a million watts about a megawatt
of continuous electric power that runs
the entire world of Second Life zooming
in on the map here you can see this
little area and then as
zoom back here we get we get to the
whole of Second Life which is actually
about the size at this point of about to
San Francisco's it's about a hundred
square miles and it has tens of millions
of user-created objects in it which
which brings me to another point let's
look at mine let's look at my notes here
it's just cool
so more is different you know when we
started with Second Life and when you
look at one of those little tiny you
know cubes that I was playing with there
you're struck by the thought that this
in and of itself isn't very interesting
that one little object with a little bit
of code on it isn't going to do very
much but what you want to keep in mind
is that things take on very different
properties emergent properties as you
scale them up and so right from the
get-go we built second life to be this
tiled simulation where you could just
basically start with dirt second life
was initially 16 of these server
machines and nothing but sort of some
grass this island that we're standing on
now obviously I'm just I just chose it
to start out showing you things here
it's an island that was entirely built
by the one person who owns it you know
there's close to 5,000 of these islands
now from that original 16 when you
looked at those 16 simulators and a lot
of investors say in 2002-2003 that kind
of time frame did they'd look at this
dirt and grass and they'd say you've got
to be kidding me you know you guys are
first at first off it takes all this
computing power for you guys to run this
ridiculous thing and second of all
you're expecting a bunch of people that
you don't know to build everything and
from what you're showing me so far I see
a stupid box that you can click on and
change colors none of this stuff is
going to be very pretty but there we get
this idea of emergent properties and of
very very large systems and you know in
the in the words of the physicist Philip
Anderson Moore is very different and so
as this thing grew and as it came to
contain millions of objects you started
to see things really come to life you
started to see people competing with
each other one person would make
something and the next person to come
into second life would obviously be
struck by how pretty it was and ask
themselves the question of whether they
could make something that was nicer than
that and so what we told those investors
and this convinced none of them to
invest in us but what we told them was
just
wait it's all gonna get better and this
is eventually gonna look good I I read a
blog post from somebody an investor
earlier today saying well the second
life thing is cool but it doesn't really
have the kind of mainstream appeal of
something like World of Warcraft
everybody seems to misunderstand this
concept of emergence second life was so
ugly in the beginning you wouldn't have
believed it it looked like a cardboard
shantytown as you flew around the
mainland looked at what everybody was
doing we haven't changed the technology
all that much but it's gotten more and
more and more compelling looking as it's
grown so very very different when you do
something like this at the scale that
we're doing it again you know a million
watts of power and five thousand
machines is it it's a lot of equipment
this is a this is a different kind of
thing the other thing that's interesting
and you really saw that when I was
whoops
getting still learning my Mac here and
yes we run on Mac and Windows and Linux
the other thing is that all of this is
done in one contiguous space as I said
before you know a the web has the
metaphor of hyperlinking it has this
idea that you can always jump from one
page to the next and in that sense all
the pages are connected some of the
attempts that people have made
historically to create you know the
Metaverse to create 3d spaces online
have failed to recognize that what's so
critically important is that all of this
stuff happen in one big space if you're
going to have emergent properties if
you're going to have people able to at
every scale if you will create something
amazing you have to make it all
connected to itself and so Second Life
is connected in a couple of different
ways one is that it's literally right
next to each other but each one of these
little squares by the way that we see on
the screen I'm circling one their each
one of those you know is another one of
these little server machines
you can walk everywhere from everywhere
in second life it's all connected and so
what I think that did was that fueled
that emergent growth holding it at the
maximum level because you were just
always encountering what your neighbor
was doing now the the one world thing is
another reason why like nobody ever
wanted to invest in this people said but
wait you know if I'm putting up a
nightclub I mean I want control I want
to set where the Sun is in the sky and I
want to I don't want any neighbors I
don't want some goofy neighbor with a
you know a tiki hut I want to control
the whole experience and when you come
to my nightclub I'm gonna show you
everything and somehow strangely and I
think we had the right intuition about
this that was just that just isn't the
right idea it's what everybody
individually wants it's not what makes
things happen it's not the way the real
world works and so from the very GetGo
we believe that the economy the objects
the literally the physical terrain of
second life had to be one world that
everybody could be a part of so that was
something very important as well so
let's see
so that's kind of that's kind of the
world so that's the and frankly my
background is physics and computers
programming the the piece that we sort
of started with as I said the the yen
the environment a second life was this
world simulation we were trying to build
a world simulator what I think we have
learned a lot about I know I have
learned a lot about as time has gone by
is now what happens to you when you put
yourself into that place not just you
know the digital representation of me as
an avatar here but what what kind of you
know Who am I what does it mean to sort
of inject yourself into a digital space
so and I think before we do this I'm
going to try to go somewhere so the
first line there is the gateway drug
Stewart and I were just talking about
this with respect to Burning Man there
is an in there is a property inherent in
the experience of projecting one's
identity in one way or another into the
computer and then interacting with other
people in real time there's this magical
thing that Second Life takes advantage
of that the text/chat and for it took
advantage of which is that when the
environment has the property that you're
sort of there but you're not really
there you're not really making eye
contact but you kind of are and you see
you're close but you're not close it has
this fascinating kind of indirect
property you you get this gateway drug
effect and what I mean by that is that
you're willing to connect with people
and share information with them and
create bonds and create friendships in a
very rapid potent way that I don't think
in real life we can ever achieve except
under unusual circumstances like Burning
Man for people that have seen that go on
to it so to show you that let me see
I've got let's see here oh where was I
now see I've
I don't have my I don't have my instant
message from Dustin here now you can
look up people and know oh he's not
online I'm in trouble what I'm gonna try
to do right now let's see if our you can
look for events in second life um to
talk about to talk about what it's like
to be a person in second life I thought
I'd try to find us some live music to go
listen to this is pretty cool okay let's
try this I just teleported jumping to
somewhere new the other thing that's
amazing about Second Life is it's it's
it's if we had to ship this environment
to you like as a video game if we had to
put it on DVD and send it to you it
would at this point it's it's about 25
or 30 terabytes of data so it would be a
big it would be a big shipping carton of
these things and you'd get really sick
of changing the disc
what I'm looking for is oh look at all
the little green people over there oh
this is great this is a this is a club
called Cecilia's and this is a live
music club so I figured this was a
perfect place to talk about we'll see
what's going on here for a second and
then I'll probably mute this so
yeah this is my last song of the night
that's live done this year one song
morning
I'm trying to find who's singing here
and I'm going to play for you guys
tonight I hope you've enjoyed the show
please stick around
Linden Hart is coming up next
[Music]
and I'm gonna explain the the person
who's playing here and I'm looking for
oh there she is okay okay this is just
crazy
salindra n' who i've seen in second life
before in fact i can say she's singing
right now live wherever she is
and everybody's dancing and listening to
her I'm gonna kick off my little
translator here we got too much cruft on
the screen here
so what she's doing right now is sitting
in her house or her home studio and
she's playing this music for us for all
the people that are here in the club and
she's streaming it live at 128 kilobits
to us as an mp3 file and we're listening
to it so I can ask her to actually when
she's done I'll ask her to give us a
shout out one of the coolest things I
always enjoy us as Philip Linda and
everybody knows my name because linden
is the last name of the the Linden's the
company here
I'm want one you didn't give me one in
the convention
no storm can say
my aunt mom's gone so I'm telling her
[Music]
make it easier
[Music]
please
she was actually I think at our
community conference which was this
summer which was right here in this room
for anybody or American so that's weird
but so wait a minute now what was I
going to talk about so what is it what
is it the jacket yeah I don't know oh oh
oh the jacket oh you mean my leather
jacket there's only one of those she
knows that so I'm going to sit down in
the chair here for a moment
surrounded by all these people and talk
about a couple of things about about
being virtual one of the things that
people
this is a game of can I interest you
more than the screen stuffs all streams
so everybody will kind of come in here
but when people think about being
digital they I think traditionally
regarded as being a little bit anonymous
and in some sense in the sense that your
true name your physical identity is
hidden behind your virtual identity
there is a degree of anonymity but
actually so the thing that's so
interesting about the this in this sort
of an environment is there's actually an
opposite thing that happens there's an
there's a what is the opposite of being
anonymous when it with respect to your
digital identity it is so easy to create
the world around you in second life it
is so easy to say who you want to be I
mean if you look at my clothing here I
mean now I'm something of an icon
because I sort of left these clothes on
after I made him a couple of years ago
because people came to know me as having
them on and so I never changed my
clothes but if you meet people in second
life what you will see now I mean let's
just take a look you know at these two
the choices that people make about their
identities here are easier to make than
it is in the real world to say who we
want to be and so when you walk up to
somebody in second life if I sit down I
could walk over here and sit and talk to
this person
but when you look at the jewelry here
and you look at you look at her you know
pink lips and you look at the fact that
she's wearing an earring that
oh that's people clapping
run that download it there's a whole
prim hair this is so great like a great
conference you get the side chatter
going on while I'm talking here macat
the the details that each person and the
time they take in choosing who they want
to be what you begin to realize is that
an opposite sort of thing is happening
you are projecting your at identity into
this space in a more facile and detailed
way than you typically do in reality in
the real world we can make these excuses
like well I'm busy or I don't have
enough money to really dress the way I
want to dress or put the art in my
apartment the way I want to that's not
the real me what you're seeing is just
an issue of convenience but in second
life and in these digital worlds to come
we don't have that level of difficulty
there is no cost of goods it doesn't
cost anything to make things here there
are tens of thousands of clothing
designers in second life if you fail to
find clothes that you think suit you in
second life you're there's something
wrong with you
there's there's so much stuff here so if
you know simply you know ditto your
people always want me to come and visit
with them your house who your neighbors
are all the details of your life are so
plastic here that you find yourself
externalizing your thoughts and your
intentions much more than you actually
do in the real world and we should come
back to that when we talk about kind of
you know futures and the meaning of
things let's seek do I have to stand up
to see my notes here I just love this
I've never had the opportunity to just
sit and wander around and goof off I
usually have to use the PowerPoint
slides the some of our dreams so one of
the questions I get and it's really cool
for us to have made the progress that we
have in this and you know how people
actually seriously ask this question as
they say well science fiction The Matrix
Snow Crash you pick it
has imagined are you guys laughing at
the missing the invisible person yeah
that's actually a bug now that's not an
intentional projection of identity it's
an accidental projection of identity if
people ask me a lot well you guys built
the matrix what what's different what's
different about the matrix than the one
that we've imagined in in in film and in
fiction you know the the imagined
Metaverse in the movies
it always has a consistent aesthetic
style right
we all wear black trench coats and we're
all kind of deadly and you know where
our hair is slicked back you know that's
a pretty common theme there you know
there's cyber dystopia actually if you
think about it if the digital world is a
world that belongs to us and if it's to
be real in this important sense that we
are able to create it then what you
expect is that it's sort of this sum of
all our dreams is the statistical
average of everything we want so what
people have built in Second Life is a
world you know I'll pull the camera back
here you know it's a world that is what
they wanted and it's a world of of
everyone's aspirations you know it's
it's it's a world of old ships and it's
a world of scuba diving and it's a world
of it's a world that has bathrooms
because we value bathrooms it's a world
that had has Ferraris and Rolexes and
it's a world that as I've said a lot of
times what we all want is a sort of
Frank Lloyd Wright cantilevered house on
that Cliff Los Angeles there's some palm
trees and below there's a dock where we
have a little powerboat and we watch the
sunset from the from the deck that is in
some sense the statistical average of
our dreams and so I think that's really
interesting that the more plastic we
make the world the more it resembles
whatever it is we want so that's another
thought about
about identity
so there's just so many opportunities to
goof around here
trying to think if I've missed any of
the basic sort of enabling capabilities
as I said before a lot of these people's
identities solyndra ins for example
where is she she everybody's a cylinder
Ian fan we got another guy up here on
stage singing now I don't I don't have
him on but
boy I don't know what he's doing let me
kind of walk out out of the madness here
I don't know why I'm walking like that
either the bugs they come when you do
the demos so let's so let me let me take
a bit of time and having shown you the
world and what it is to be a part of it
let me meditate a little bit on the
things that we're learning now again
everybody who looked at this thing kind
of conventionally would say historically
would say well you guys have got this
wacky kind of thing like the well or
something where there's all these
incredibly creative thinking people
there's only a few thousand of them this
was like in 2004 and the character of
this thing in the feature set and the
sensibilities of it are all driven by
this crazy bunch of creative people that
have been nuts enough to figure out this
complicated UI and get a really fast
computer and everything so they can run
it and so people have always said well
there's going to be this split in the
beginning there's going to be thirty
forty percent of the people are going to
be making the content that everybody
else is consuming in other words
everybody is going to be a creator and
then as things grow it's going to be
like the real world it almost nobody
makes anything and everybody almost
everybody almost all of the time is just
a consumer like we consume media and we
consume clothing and we consume houses
and everything else what if that wasn't
true there's a lot of there's actually
been some suggestion of this if you look
at things like the sort of web 2.0 you
know YouTube and video and what people
have been doing is they've been given
increasingly the ability to create
things online but in second life you
probably see this brought to a
to a point of focus that you don't see
anywhere else when people are given the
ability to make things to create when
we're all given the ability to be quite
creative compared to real life we take
it we seem willing to be creative to a
degree that there doesn't appear to be
any end to we will we will sort of make
our environment and share it with others
and meet people and make things with
them be creative to a degree that
doesn't appear to have an end we have
gone in in 19 in the beginning of this
year we had a hundred thousand people in
Second Life that had signed up many less
people that were actively using it now
we have 1.7 million people that have
signed up so that's a 17 factor growth
this year it's still 30% the statistics
we have that indicate how much time
people spend making stuff is not
changing significantly people are still
taking advantage of the plasticity of
the environment and making it their own
and that doesn't seem to be changing as
more and more mainstream people come
into second life so that's my first
point about the future if we use
technology to enable the world to be
deeply mutable by us we will it seems to
a degree that I think we've sort of
forgotten because of the technology of
media and the difficult how expensive it
is to build a car you know or a computer
chip we have sort of lost in a sense in
modern technology our ability to be
creative and these digital worlds are
going to bring it back and what that
means is that the world's gonna have a
lot more variety second life hasn't
gotten any less nuts as it's grown one
bit there's there's just as much stuff
as ever so plasticity plasticity is
something that we all seem to well ow
we should go on there's like skydiving
there's all kinds of crazy things I
could do here it is so funny to try and
challenge myself to run a presentation
where I'm simultaneously using Second
Life and talking I don't like it yeah
yeah I gotta take this I got it you know
what see I gotta take this darn thing
off here and put it on the ground I keep
sweeping into my leg the time machine
idea there what that bring it back
everything happens a lot faster in
second life because there is much more
facile communication there is an ability
to very rapidly prototype things try out
new ideas find a business partner get
married everything happens faster there
so there's a generalized property of
second life and I believe also of
virtual worlds and virtualization in
general that suggests that yes we are
going to continue to sort of accelerate
the time skills associated with
virtually everything we do I guess for
some people that's a depressing or
stress causing thought and for others
it's very exciting but it definitely
seems to be the case here so people tend
to use second life today for things like
sort of taste testing and prototyping
and things where you can sort of use
that time machine quality Starwood for
example put a hotel in Second Life we
could go see it at the aloft hotel they
haven't built this hotel in the real
world yet they built it in Second Life
with the idea being that people would
come and wander around they actually had
an artist Ben Folds play a party at the
in the lobby of the hotel with the idea
that people would come to the hotel
wander around go in the rooms and give
them feedback on whether it was a good
hotel they built it very accurately and
they got you know 25 or 30 meaningful
reviews from people you know emails and
stuff after they did that so they were
able to exploit the fact that it is just
cheaper and faster to do things in there
than it is to do them here everything's
free so you know with media today we've
got this thing we're contending with
that says that if you're an artist you
know reproducing your music is
technologically trending towards being
zero cost and unless
you try to legislate against that which
is seems fruitless given how many
countries there are and how many
different approaches people can take to
this you are not going to be able to
stop the the physics so to speak of that
cost equation that things are going to
become freer and freer well second life
is the ultimate extension of that
because everything is free in fact the
only scarce resource and stewart was
reminding me earlier that I think Jaron
Lanier perhaps said this almost 20 years
ago the only natural resource in this
future virtual world is creativity as a
pragmatic technologist I'd put a little
common than say and also computing
resources as people sadly know in second
life there is only so much grid here to
extract simulation power from but but
pragmatically and or strategically in
the limit of computation the only thing
that's precious in this environment is
creativity and so things like you as a
brand you as a famous person in second
life is meaningful the idea of you
charging a fixed price for every copy of
an article of clothing is probably not
as meaningful long-term so again there
is a pressure there toward diversity so
that's another thing we learn about the
future in a future where the cost of
goods descends and ascends and descends
I think it's less likely that there will
be big mass market concepts I've always
found it amusing that the sort of
dystopia is imagined by science fiction
inevitably made the world more grey made
it more monochromatic that's so very
unlikely to be true because these costs
of production of prototyping and of
distribution are reduced to virtually
zero by this type of an environment and
again I think Second Life we've focused
on making that empowering that because
we so wanted emergence to drive
everything but this is just going to be
intrinsically true of any of these
systems because there's no there's only
bits moving around here I wrote down
there I wrote orgy and rebirth you know
there's a funny thing about second life
everybody says oh my god if I see
another dance club I'm gonna puke or you
know all the jewellery are the bling we
didn't see that dunno if anybody noticed
you know that the the jewelry all
scintillates with little
reflections it's just funny another
interesting thing I'd say about digital
worlds is that they provide this
cathartic environment in which we can
work through all the stuff that we
always wanted to do you know we can have
as much sex as we want to have we can we
can have a Ferrari we can fly an
airplane we can go skydiving we can have
that house on the hill that I talked
about earlier and then and I think this
is the uplifting and inspiring part we
can kind of move on and start thinking
about what's next and so when you go to
Second Life and I encourage you to try
it you know you see this interesting
super positioning of people that are
kind of just doing that you know I'm
gonna live life to the fullest relative
to the desires that I have now in the
real world and then on top of that and
in the margins and in the spaces between
things you find these odd and
interesting people who are kind of now
they've reached that zen-like calm where
they've sated they've satiated
themselves with all of this stuff and
they're sort of thinking about what
they're gonna do next
so that's another thought about about
the future here maybe we're gonna well
maybe we're going to become less
materialistic in a way just because
we're gonna have so much the future of
work to a great degree and this has
actually really been pioneered in some
of the massively multiplayer games like
World of Warcraft in World of Warcraft
if you have 200 people that are in your
guild that are willing to go and fight
battles for you they're all paying you
to be a part of your team they don't
have to be there they can walk away at
any time and so inherently inherently
management and organization happens
differently an environment in which
people have so many options and are so
much fundamentally freer and so I think
that's something that's very important
there are 20 30 40 person companies
making you know approaching
multi-million dollar annual revenues in
Second Life building content things like
that Hotel that I mentioned earlier for
the most part those our companies
organized of people that met in Second
Life they don't even necessarily know
each other's physical identities they
work together entirely in the
environment there is a profound
decentralization that's being
tested as an experiment if you will here
in this world and what it is showing is
what I think a lot of modern thinkers
have already told us which is that
decentralization generally works better
that businesses can operate more
efficiently that people could operate
together better when they are very very
free to make their own strategic
judgments about what they should do and
then you sort of see the emergence some
of who's able to be effective as a
manager or an organizer under those
conditions rather than these sort of
monarchic work environments that we have
today where the CEO you know you live in
that town and there's four or five
companies you could work at but you know
you're better off not telling off the
CEO corollary to that is that people are
starting to do a lot of business
meetings in second life a lot of
business meetings real-world business
meetings I mean like IBM you know having
a team meeting and the reason that
they're doing that I don't think it's
necessarily because those meetings are
empowered fundamentally from the content
perspective by being done in second life
but instead because they're more fun and
you're more likely to you know speak the
truth in those meetings so that's a
fascinating thing to think about again
we all came into this thinking well
we're gonna use technology to somehow
make business meetings better I think
most business meetings aren't of any
value so you can't improve on zero but
you could make it more fun
so the museum New York so therefore I
say that if if digital environments are
likely to be premier environments for
collaboration and creativity if we're
gonna move a lot of intellectual energy
into second life into in the things like
Second Life into cyberspace then what is
actually going to happen to the real
world so my last thought before we take
some questions and going at whatever
direction we want here look at some
other stuff and Second Life is I really
believe that particularly the places
where we have conventionally gathered to
work the skyscrapers of New York when I
look into the future people say what's
going to happen here I get this feeling
and it's a weird thought but I think
it's true that these are going to become
kind of like museums kind of like how we
visit the old like
we visit the old you know paper mill
that's down the way that you know you go
and see it now you still go to it
there's still people wandering through
it but they're wandering through it as a
museum a memory we're going to move the
most facile collaborative creative
aspects of our intentions and our
thought and our actions into the virtual
worlds for all the reasons that I've
talked about here they're just it's
easier it's better it's higher
resolution it's you know it just has all
these amazing properties and I think
what that means is that fairly quickly
probably quicker than as is usually the
case with these exponential technology
curves slower at the beginning and then
much faster than any of us thought
toward the end I think we really are
going to fundamentally change the the
nature of how we look at the real world
I think we're going to look at it as
historical in a way that is exciting and
difficult to imagine so let me let me
transition there to questions goofing
around whatever we want to do here
I was amazing thank you you've got these
cards I should have mentioned earlier go
ahead and write questions on them
they'll come up to Kevin and they'll
he'll pass on the good ones up to me a
couple things that we chatted about just
before the audience came in one was I
was asking you know what are the
limitations on this in terms of sort of
scale in the world where are the
residents now in the world of the you
know that 1.7 million are they all in
California or in the US or what right
about half of Second Life residents are
in the United States today about half of
them are outside the proportion is
increasing quite rapidly we've just
created language translation
capabilities you can switch the UI to a
bunch of different languages right now
the run rate for new signups is more I
think it's more than 50% outside the
United States where especially outside
the u.s. in the UK English speaking is
first and foremost than Northern Europe
mm-hmm
big contingent in Australia but we are
in you know 130 countries there's people
there's 4,000 or maybe it's like 8,000
now I suppose I was like a month ago
people in Turkey mm-hmm that have Second
Life accounts so very exciting in fact
you you mentioned that I got my
translator I'll show you this this is
just so incredibly cool one of the one
of the gadgets I've got here I had it on
there earlier as is this little
translator toy that somebody built I
found it you can see it down there at
the bottom of the screen I'm turning it
on here you see I can pick English up
here and I can pick Japanese over here
and then I can say you know now there's
probably gonna be somebody in the
audience here you can check this out to
San Francisco
and then watch right below that in kanji
ZnO less yeah that's actually being done
by sending the text that I type to
babble fish and then getting back the
response and if I I have walked around
second life I've gone to the Japanese
island with it I mean there's lots of
different places where people obviously
there's no segregation but there's an
island that is mostly people from Japan
and I've sat there and spoken to them
bi-directionally watching their kanji
translated into English you can't do
that in the real world as much as people
would have you believe you can buy these
little gadgets because it's just too
hard you don't know the timing but in
second life you have enough time to wait
and that sounds like another reason to
do certain kinds of business meetings in
second life where you've got people from
various cultures you want to use their
own language and translate all their
bright ideas through Babel Fish makes
that makes them even brighter usually
it's a comedy it economic experience to
talk to people with Babel the question
else comes up with these things do women
use this thing at all so right now there
are about fifteen to sixteen thousand
people in Second Life about forty three
percent of them are women as it stands
today I think the reason that it's less
women use second life on an hours base
is quite a bit more than men do by quite
a bit I mean like thirty to forty
percent more there so that accounts for
the difference I think the reason that
it's 43 percent total concurrency and
not sixty percent is because second life
still requires an extremely fast
graphics card to use which I I would
hazard the guess that if you're female
and you have bought a personal computer
you're less likely to buy one with an
Nvidia 8800 graphics card or whatever
that you need to run it to run this fast
because so many games have been male in
their demographics how about age the
median age is 32 but the older you are
the more you use second life second life
is not as heavily used in the sort of 18
to 24 year old category where all the
games are focused and the older you get
the more you use it and again you know
pretty consistent with the basic
experience and ideas do you have a
theory why older people will spend more
time on it well I think that the
fundamental promise that the name makes
[Laughter]
is is pretty I'd I you know I've
conversed with people who have pretty
much echoed that there's a great story
one of our employees was a woman I was
interviewing her and she told me this is
just so cool she's a big Second Life
user her mom was a big Second Life user
she's at a night club she's dressed up
she's dancing in Second Life and her mom
shows up course nobody knows this my
mom's you know she knows her mom's
second life name mom is dressed up you
know to kill and this woman I am her mom
and says mom you know good you know it's
crazy and her mom's her mom I am sure
like you know piss off you know I want
to live my own life and then she tells
me her mom 80 and living here's a
question for Chris at Duffield where are
you at Christa field right down here is
second life archived will future users
be able to visit second life's of the
past or as just a rolling now it is just
in the now right now and of course the
reason for that is that we are right at
the edge of disk space and computation
so making time slices of it is something
the Internet Archive a second life does
not exist yet and it's probably to take
a decade or something for capacity to so
exceed the limits of what people are
able to do in here that that starts to
become possible and people archive their
own experience in second life on their
own box no interesting you you that the
conditional no there's some things you
can do to copy and you know store your
own content we want to make that better
but pragmatically mm-hm it's hard it's a
lot of data Adrienne Cotter has a
question right over here is there evil
in second life is that one of the
emergent properties yeah there is in
fact I think that it is inherent in a
complex system anything as complicated
as second life is going to be a place
where you can do wonderful things you
can also piss people off the crime and
second life is fraud it's what we call
griefing which is just making people mad
to the point where they want to be there
anymore and there's as much of it there
I think as there is here in some ways
but you're a little safer so that
SURS begins - answer Josh's question how
many people have had accounts suspended
and for doing what the fundamentally
accounts suspended banned from Second
Life probably in the hundreds now so
statistically the answer is surprisingly
few Pierre Omidyar an investor in Linden
Lab says you know eBay was founded on
the belief that people were basically
good I'd go a little farther to say that
if the lights are on in the room and
they're really bright people are
basically good
Second Life is a transparent society to
a profound degree we were talking about
this you do not have anonymity in your
identity you are who you are and so you
are fearful of compromising that
relationship is there a true name behind
every handle in that sense yeah so you
can find the real person although this
again you can have a few accounts we
haven't solved that problem completely
of true names you know there's not a
biometric that ties the second life
account to you probably some day there
will be validation and verification
systems that'll actually do that you'll
be able to choose you know who you want
to trust here's a question from Kevin
Kelly speaking of evil I added that why
not try the grand experiment of
eliminating copyrights for creation
embrace the universal copy bot and let
all creation remain in the public domain
is it too late to try that right on very
rich discussion as Kevin might know and
in Second Life a huge issue people argue
about copyrights all the time I think
that Second Life has a number of
communities emerging in it that have
very different rules whether or not you
fundamentally embrace copyrights say
within the local concept of community is
definitely a testable assertion I mean
you can you can set your objects in
Second Life to be indefinitely copyable
by everybody else or even everybody
within a an enclosed group freely and so
you can test that I think what we've got
going on here is a kind of a test of
that that will stabilize at some real
value that I think will be fairly well I
think it'll be a lot closer to it'll
it'll be a lot
more liberal and more copyable than what
we have say in copyright law today I
don't think there's the ability or
there's going to be it's going to be
likely that everybody in second life is
going to manage to enforce and continue
extending copyright law the way sadly
we've seen it you know done here you
mentioned that there's five thousand
islands on the islands do people get to
sort of make alternative versions of the
world or the economy works differently
or I don't know that the physics works
differently or something yeah you know
there are places where you can you can
kill people there are guns in Second
Life I was shooting one earlier before
everybody came in so there are a lot of
experiments going on you know there's
very liberal communes that you can
experiment with you can't turn off
gravity everybody always wants to turn
off gravity there's not a thing to turn
off gravity yet we'll probably put it in
at some point it's hard from a
computational perspective because then
everything scattered up to infinity you
know above the the ground but but there
are a lot of experiments in different
sort of ways of living that are going on
and going on you know to a much richer
degree as you can imagine than in the
real world
Michael Shree gas a variation on the the
violence and pestilence question are
there no barbarians no world of warfare
crowd wants to come over and colonize
second life all barbarians like from
world of from world of warcraft ecology
yeah that happens all the time actually
yeah that's that's one of the funniest
one of the funniest things to see happen
in Second Life is actually to see an
intentional group of people miscreants
in many cases coming in to just torment
everybody in second life kind of gets
seduced by the environment so it happens
a lot people will come in and they'll
kind of you know 80% of them will go
back to playing World of Warcraft or
whatever and you know they'll have a
hoot you know for a while and then
they'll a group of them will basically
stick around and start building
something about you again I again I
think with the lights on with with a
transparent environment people are
basically creative and basically good
but yes that's one of the funniest
I shouldn't say funny I mean sometimes
it's funny and then sometimes it's it's
frustrating for us because we'd like to
have better systems to help at least
minimally police things but yeah people
do come in that way there are barbarians
you haven't said much about the economy
in Second Life and Wall Street Journal
in all these places Forbes and Business
Week and so on are all over Second Life
trying to understand how come you get up
basically a real functioning token
economy that intersects with the dollar
economy and in the strange and
continually marvelous ways what can you
say about the what you're learning about
the economy of second life well
fundamentally we always wanted a market
environment to dominate the physics of
the world beyond the beyond the sort of
automata of local rules that was the
basic world simulation that I talked so
much about we really believed that the
market was the best conversation for
what was going to be a value and what
wasn't and so we built a currency system
and we actually allow that currency to
float against the US dollar this is a
fascinating issue why do we do that well
because the GDP the productivity in
second life as both the technology and
the user based scales is going up at a
more rapid rate than the number of
people and so what we actually do just
like the Federal Reserve is we actually
print new money and put it into second
life with the goal of keeping the
exchange rate roughly constant and so it
bizarre we do the same thing that that a
government does in managing the money
supply how do you actually calculate
what the metabolic rate is economically
in that do you have some script that
tells you that well that the traditional
basket of goods is obviously kind of out
the window because you don't need
anything to survive here
so food and shelter and clothing is it's
kind of meaningless but what we do is we
look at the average amount of money that
people spend in a transaction we look at
their total amount of money they're
spending over unit time we look at the
diversity of objects that are being
bought and sold and again by the way as
you could imagine the contrarian thing
that happens here is people who have
probably heard like Adidas Nike Starwood
Toyota everybody's in Second Life these
companies are doing
we're doing really amazing things but
they are as yet invisible against the
backdrop of content that people create
so the diversity of stuff that's bought
and sold is almost as large as the
number of transactions it's like
everything was a one-off here several
people have asked how do you make money
this a subscription deal and what's the
where does the money come into linden so
the way we make money is for the most
part and I'll simplify here for this
discussion we basically rent that land
because we're operating at this point
all of these machines that simulate the
world we don't anticipate by the way
that's going to grow much faster than we
can put machines online so it's going to
become we think internet like in the way
this all works in other words people
should be able to run their own
simulators and services but for today
the way we make money is we basically
charge $20 an acre a month for all the
land so it's kind of the entrepreneurs
dream again we wanted to spur a lot of
creative entrepreneurship so just like
moving you know we always looked at
Second Life as this big empty country
we're trying to get people to immigrate
and so and we're trying to get people
that were creative and entrepreneurial
to emigrate so we always we just said
well what about just a flat you know
unimproved property tax what if that's
the only thing fa no sales tax no income
tax just have property tax so that's how
we make our money actually those 5,000
machines each have 16 acres of land 20
dollars an acre it adds up to a lot of
money so we're doing fine you know that
way so that's a artificially created
scarce resource there's only so much
land that you've created a hundred
square miles or whatever is up to by now
and so you expand that basically it
sounds like
linearly with the number of residents
yeah yeah there's actually a fixed cost
associated with putting new land online
which people have to pay so there's a
kind of a pay for a new server fee that
happens and that regulates in a market
way how rapidly new land is created
people always ask hey there's just an
infinity of land here and no there's not
that's actually a critical element of a
stable system like this you don't want
there to be a million square miles of
land because what people will do is
they'll spread themselves out so much
they can't see their neighbors and then
they'll complain that there's nobody to
play with
so cities keep coming back
question from ash ash yes H right over
there
what type of behavior tracking are you
doing in other words what most how do
most people spend their time well the
most common activities it Sarah I mean
you know there's a whole category people
out there doing Google researched with
their basic data there must be people
doing research within the Second Life
now what people do well fundamentally
you know much like again much like the
net there's too much data here to do a
whole lot of that with and I think
that's great I mean I think
fundamentally you're gonna you're gonna
have a basic desire for privacy around
what you're doing in here that's you
know akin to the real world and we have
to respect that
are there people doing you know
marketing analysis and Second Life yeah
I guess I actually have an ethics policy
there's there's you know 30 or 40
universities teaching classes at any
time in Second Life including places
like Harvard we actually have in that
case an ethics policy around don't don't
bother people too much if you're you
know if you're being a sociologist and
you're studying people in second life
you have to treat them with the same
respect and rules that you do in the
real world we don't in terms of what
people are doing the most in Second Life
I'd say the best thing we know we can
look at things like gross transaction
levels and things the best that we could
say is kind of what I said before which
is people kind of play and shop and go
to dance clubs and stuff a lot like the
real world and then there's a smaller
percentage of kind of exploration beyond
that kind of emergent sort of guidelines
and rules have you come on I mean the
Burning Man
bye-bye they vanished dogs and they said
park your car and get out of it and from
then on bike and and walk there's all
kind of rules like that ever emerged
there's a head-to there's great rules
like that like you can we let you
basically put anything on your avatar
you want you can have shiny jewelry and
you can have prim hair you saw some
people talking about that which is I
don't I am you know one of the Eco
sensitive people who doesn't have prim
hair the more stuff you're wearing as an
individual makes you more beautiful but
it also slows down the experience for
everybody else
so there are emergent rules like take
all that crap
if you're coming to a public lecture
like this and there's things like that
there's there's a lot of rules around
behavior when it's appropriate to speak
people are surprisingly quiet in a group
discussion in Second Life it's very
compelling you you can easily have this
number of people and be reading the chat
and you know so long as it's a not
intentionally gregarious or you know
mean crowd you you you get a stable
environment here's a question I bet you
get a lot of from amber Kerr weighing
back there waving your hand do you think
there is a possibility that Second Life
detracts from its users first lives
their real lives
for example they find solace and virtual
relationship other than maintaining
their real world relationships what's
the divorce rate come on
yep actually I should know that there
there is a divorce concept you can
actually have a partner and the same is
true with sailboats by the way yeah but
let me say this let me say a couple
things well first let me tell you a
story there's a guy named max Mondesi
he's a well-known guy in Second Life
built skyscrapers built furniture
buildings he got on our forums one time
he said I lost 70 pounds while using
Second Life now this was a guy who
sometimes was clocking over a hundred
hours a week there's a lot of people who
do that much secondly and so everybody
got on the forums including me I was one
of the first ones and said max you know
your weight should go in the opposite
direction while you're using second life
and I said what happened and he said
well I've been here for a couple of
years now and every day every few days
I'm tweaking my avatar I'm getting a new
piece of clothing I'm keeping up with
the trends I'm putting on whatever I'm
going down going out and he said at some
point it just struck me it's so easy to
modify my avatar could it really be all
that hard to modify my body and and
there anecdotally have been a lot of
stories like that I think though the big
picture question about is second life
making you dumber and smarter is is
answered by the question of well what
are you doing there if you're sort of
treating second life like a lemonade
stand you're trying to make a little
extra money or you're trying to convince
people to do something or you're trying
to prototype some some architecture or
build an airplane or whatever
let me tell you Second Life presents you
with more intellectual challenge around
socialization and business formation and
friendship and programming and
everything else as deep as you want to
go so to speak it presents you with more
challenge than than the real world so I
would boldly make the opposite argument
which is for a lot of people or at least
opportunistically not for everybody but
if you want it to it can be the case
that it can actually make you smarter to
be sitting in front of the computer and
doing this because it's exposing you to
a higher degree of intellectual
challenge debatable we can talk about it
more there's a question from Aaron the
waltz rumberger
right over here do you think someone
could make a living by working only in
second life at this point hundreds of
people do there was a woman who did a
press release earlier this week we
didn't do it it was funny because it
worked we've grown so much now we were
getting calls to confirm whether this
was actually true Sansha Chung who
graced the cover of Businessweek a few
months back who is a land baron in
second life she basically owns and
resells real estate and rents it and she
has a million dollars at this point in
assets in the value of the land Linden
dollars or US dollars u.s. so that's a
ton of Linden dollars it's two hundred
and fifty million Linden dollars in
million so she's actually making a big
living people making clothing in second
life jewelry furniture running these
nightclubs like the one that we were in
you know that live act your you got a
whole economy that's behind that many of
those people it's their full-time job
believe it or not uh the total economy
is again I won't touch much in the
economy the total economy of Second Life
is about ten million US dollars a month
in exchanges between people not not what
we make in in goods and services
transact it so there's a big pie there
to have a piece of how much money exists
since you're the creator of it do you
know the total about five million
dollars so that's fascinating for those
who are in it macroeconomics the
velocity the rate at which money changes
hands in second life is about two
hundred percent a month so that's like
total you know really holding down the
fast
our button on the time machine Alex
Whistler where are you Alex
right here is there a third life on the
horizon where will the exponential
acceleration of a technology take second
life well and again we were chatting
about this little earlier people seemed
amazingly incapable of extrapolating
technology trends they always believed
technology will affect them more in the
immediate future and they don't they're
unwilling to even embrace what's going
to happen farther out the first thing
that's going to happen here and it's
absolutely certain if you see movies
today you see scenes that were created
entirely using CG they were created
using computers okay in a movie today
given a whole lot of offline processing
you can create scenes that look you
can't tell the difference between them
and reality well in just a few years
time as this technology moves as it
always does for mainframes so to speak
to to real-time processing on PCs Second
Life is going to look like a movie now
think how that's going to affect you you
watch the trees blow in the wind and you
watch the the birds fly by they're going
to be at the resolution and detail of
what you see in the real world there
won't be any difference the claim that
oh I'm not going to get into this
because it doesn't look real enough yeah
yeah well just give it a couple of years
so I think that's one thing and then I
think looking way farther out at
technology as I said we're gonna move a
lot of our creative energy into here and
I think that you know the sort of the
whole singularity discussion of how much
computation we'll be able to do once
it's here when a scripted object is is
complicated as your brain what's it
going to be able to do well that remains
to be seen what I would say is there's a
lot of people in second life that Island
in the beginning was was all I didn't
try and find it for you but there's all
these birds and there's all these a life
animals that are roaming around on that
Island it's an experiment in how far you
can go with that so that's going to
change things all that's pretty much
extrapolating and kind of a steady curve
from what we've got so far do you think
there'll be thresholds and cusps and
tipping points into you
surprising weirdness and basically work
backwards on what kinds of things that
surprised you most in the few years the
Second Life has been up now yeah yeah
you know I think emergent systems
inevitably exhibit discontinuous change
the they always things pop into view
viruses bloom and take over a whole
place things happen very quickly in
second life I think we've seen that
people have sometimes said that second
life steps through these periods of
human history right where it's initially
kind of tribalism and then you get
feudalism you know and we move through
the stages of human experience as people
kind of test the waters in here so I
think there will probably be some big
discontinuous changes you know you got
me I can't hazard sort of what the next
ones will be I think that this concept
of very very high degree of
verisimilitude and resolution will will
create some profoundly different usage
trends in here
you know today this is kind of a playing
around with autocad kind of thing you
know make my house and invite my friends
over and play a little music as the
technology changes it's very difficult
to say what the experience will be you
know you'll be able to drive a car much
more easily you can drive a car in a
second life today but it's still really
clunky well second life you described
importantly as one contiguous place but
the web also is increasingly in a sense
one contiguous place and how do is how
do you overlap with other stuff like
eBay or Google or you name it well I'm
gonna I'm gonna divert the ants for that
a little bit because people always say
well what's so different about Second
Life is its 3d it's the web in 3d the 3d
web that's talked about a lot these guys
are looking at me that's great 3d is
very powerful for a lot of reasons that
I love to talk about in terms of how our
brains work and how our memories work
but 3d is not actually what's so
different about second life the idea of
things that you do on the web being done
in 3d what is different about second
life is this modality that you are never
alone when you are at a site so to speak
you are there
implicitly with all the other people who
are there and so you're able to turn to
somebody this sort of Mystery Science
Theater you know imagine the web imagine
how fun a bad website would have been in
the late 90s if you could have turn to
the person next to you and said this is
the stupidest site I've ever seen you
know you know if I see another blinking
taggle you know kill myself so there's a
that's happening here because you're in
here with your friends you're in here
standing with other people and so I
think we say so so the long answer is
how does it relate to the web I think
the web is a more solid Cystic and alone
kind of a structure it's bibliographic
and I think that what people are going
to do is they're going to use
environments like Second Life to kind of
connect all that bibliography into
community and maybe that's what we're
seeing with a lot of the sort of you
know wide strong were strong emergent
use of the word community now on on the
web and around things like Second Life
well that relates to a question from
Jesse Cowan sharp right here in the
middle when Second Life is just one of
many virtual worlds what thoughts if any
as Linden Labs giving to
interoperability and protocols or
standards given the role that they had
in allowing the unbridled growth of the
Internet first of all we believe that
for this to go to where people want it
to go and there's abundant proof you
know in the last few months at least
finally that that's true I think that
second life's got to be an open set of
protocol standards and code for people
to be able to extend it as rapidly as
they want to I don't actually think that
there will be multiple dissimilar
virtual worlds because the cost of
establishing and maintaining identity in
particular is quite high so I think that
there will be a tremendous sort of a
power-law behavior where there will be a
lot of force that will cause these
systems to interoperate so much that
they'll be like the real world you won't
have a really strong concept of Italy
doesn't give you a different body and
you don't have a different name and when
you go to Italy you're still basically
you so I think that's what we're gonna
see with multiple virtual worlds but
they will be hosted by different people
and perhaps the software will be written
by different companies not you know just
one like ours a couple of questions on
the you know the you behavior one
as soon as common as two people have
more than one avatar on average I think
people have like 1.25 I was hard so yeah
people do but they don't have very many
and that relates directly back to what I
said earlier which is the thing you have
to see to believe and that is that
identity is such a strong thing that you
create your identity in second life and
then you keep it and yeah you know even
though you can just I didn't show you
this you know I can just drag new
clothes unto myself and just instantly
put them on you don't do it that much so
identity is a very strong thing gender
for example is strongly mapped and in
other words when you when you meet a
female avatar it's more likely it's a
female it's a woman in real life so and
again the difficulty is the subterfuge
of playing a different gender is pretty
hard in an environment that's realistic
that's interesting a related question
are there private areas in second life
yeah you can make a private area in your
basement today you know there are people
that have clubs hid and underground
we've probably flown over a few of them
already yeah there is a concept of
privacy I think we added from a design
perspective we biased toward public
space but again that was because we were
trying to start this fire of viral
emergence and we were less respectful of
people's desire for privacy in the
future people can and will build more
and more private spaces and even this
you know the the intranet if you will of
the world today I think will be
replicated you know there will be places
in second life they're like super secure
and the islands today are like that I'm
flying around on the mainland of Second
Life and the islands are more more
privatized
some of these questionnaires sound like
avatars to me someone named Bronwyn the
Zim is that they're giving out their
asks do you think playing Second Life
can make people see the real world as
more plastic as the creativity and
empowerment carry over to the real world
this is kind of a Burning Man question
yeah any minute I can not only speak for
well I mean I can on the one hand I can
speak for myself there's a tremendous
sense of focusing on what's really real
that you bring back to the real world
when you're in second life there's this
demand for PLAs
city I mean everybody to use the Second
Life a lot has tried to reach out and
zoom in on somebody you know like you're
like God darn it you know I can't do it
so there's a there's a tremendous desire
to modify the environment once you've
given been given such a power to do that
but I think that what it definitely
brings back to the real world there's a
sensibility about the value of things I
mean I think that the second life
experience overall is one where
creativity and community really that's
what there is I was just talking to a
woman on Second Life last night who was
saying that she was driving by in the
real world she's used Second Life a lot
she said but but it has only been using
it for a couple months and she said I've
been driving by some McMansions was what
she said you know and it's all there and
you know she was saying they really
strike me as being shallow now because
I'm seeing people just building this
stuff all day and Second Life and I
realized wow that's kind of fun but it
doesn't really mean all that much so I
think that's one of the very powerful
reasons why this stuff's going to grow
and and what it's going to do to us it's
interesting that real estate is is is
sort of the fundamental resource here
food is not an issue energy is not an
issue right a lot of things that you
sort of drop when you go into this world
what's going on I'm just looking at this
strange little globe here but I think
there's like a naked picture in it or
something so I'll fly by
could create its own new list of
questions they couldn't indeed getting
questions about when are we gonna get
smell touch taste we're talking about
force-feedback earlier touch coming yeah
oh boy this spook house right here is so
great this is one of the original
money-making things that was built by
this guy named Sinatra kardia it was
just the coolest I can't believe I'm
seeing it it's like a piece of history
it's been around for years it's really
quite scary too you get on that little
right there yes that they like a linden
dollar very small amount of money to
take the ride and it's really pretty
scary you did it around Halloween yeah
what did we say I forgot it to end I've
totally redirect this Oh smell touch and
taste so interfaces you know I think
that the we worked as a company we
worked on interface technology for about
the first nine months we built some
really interesting interface stuff that
was yet I had been interested in for
years
when we got that kind of working we had
also been doing some basic you know let
there be light kind of stuff with
multiple simulators and water and
objects and stuff and we just quickly
realized you know the challenge of the
the design and technology challenge and
even social challenge of building the
world that we're all gonna go into
that's the big problem and so we said we
got it we got to focus on that problem
first and then we'll come back to this
interface stuff but you know there is
interesting work being done in interface
technology there are 3d mice now for
example that are extremely impressive
this it's ministering work being done on
that you know there's there's a lot of
good stuff that's happening again the
early technology in the 80s and 90s for
that just wasn't ready yet fundamentally
you know both sensor and computing
technology wasn't fast enough to do it
but there's a lot of stuff coming so I
think that part of our strategy with
Second Life will be to open up like the
interface so that people can extend it
with with gadgetry that extends the
modality of the interface and yeah well
there's a bunch of people waiting to do
that in Second Life as it as these new
interfaces come out imagine being able
to grab something like I was grabbing
that object on the island you know and
grab it in the normal way how compelling
that would be that's going to be
something we'll be able to do in in
another
year two let's wrap it up in demo mode
you want to take us into this house here
we have something else well I boy I
don't know something else there's
another ten million things let's see if
we can see you sit down here if I
remember correctly and then yeah you go
in a mouse look meaning you look through
your eyes yeah let's see whether they
stand in front of the car sit down mouse
click this sign and pay it a dollar and
then stipes Pookie I'm gonna pay a
dollar here okay you have 60 seconds to
say spooky
and watch this do we gotta have the
audio all right I turned it on so it's
just like an amusement ride I can look
around see a little car way you get for
one linden dollar about a third of a
cent right it's moving us around in this
in this house
incredibly strangely in the evening
anyway scaring in the right environment
that can be pretty scary the first time
I get the feeling that people have gone
home at the carnival you know nothing's
happening and you wonder why
this is one of those like psychology
tests how long will we sit here scenario
no that's cool
[Laughter]
I gotta like I could go you go on and on
but why don't we wrap it up there give
him time
thank you very much indeed right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]